as ted said i'm going to be talking on
this topic of biological and demographic
causes of high hiv prevalence among msm
i'll i'll sort of
come back to the end about why this
why i think this particular topic
matters uh so much
in terms of the current state of of
dialogue and understanding about hiv
prevention among among men who have sex
with men so um the initial requisite
slide uh this one's actually somewhat
out of date i hope to update it last
night but the wireless was down at ted's
house
so this is out of date but the
information in it hasn't really changed
much or at least the take home message
hasn't changed much which is that you
know 25 years into the hiv epidemic in
the united states
uh men who have sex with men continue to
be
you know have have rates of hiv
prevalence in hiv hiv
incidents that are
you know higher than any other risk
group in in the country you know
comprise at least 50 if not more of the
new cases of hiv
um so this has been a consistent message
uh for a long time
in the u.s
so there's a sort of you know endless
message about why these large persistent
differentials exist and i think if you
asked you know the average person in the
street if you asked my mom
why this is um
yeah if you ask mrs goodra why this is
the case um after after turning beat red
she'd probably
you know
have imagine that it's because
men who have sex with men just you know
have large numbers of sex partners
relative to heterosexuals that probably
has to be the whole story
so is it you know is what to what degree
do behavioral differences
explain this story
um
perhaps some
um
the computer seems to be frozen
oh there it is okay
um
perhaps some
uh
but what often happens in the in the
conversation out there is is that
behavioral differences i think
or sort of individual level behavioral
differences don't necessarily explain as
much of this
differential as as the person on the
street thinks it does
and we often see in the world of hiv
prevention
um the sort of
then the alternative explanation
is tends to focus on the sort of bigger
structural issues of stigma which leads
to depression which changes men's rates
of health seeking behavior and sort of
all these you know bigger and homophobia
and these kind of issues that are much
more sort of ultimate and also you know
are are certainly important things to
look at
what i'm going to focus on today is is
kind of putting those on hold for a
moment not to say they're not important
not to say they're not pieces of the
story but to think about two other
pieces of the of the puzzle that um
one of which is has been well known for
a while one of which is a little bit
more subtle but both of which i think
don't get
talked about enough or don't get
included enough in this story about why
about this differential the first is the
simple
straightforward
issue that hiv infectiousness is much
higher for anal sex than it is for
vaginal sex a simple biological
difference
and the second one which is more subtle
is
the demographic difference basic
demographic difference which is that
heterosexuals are two sex population
and gay men are one sex population
what in the world does that have to do
with hiv
differentials
why does that matter
and it and it also comes down to an
issue of probability of transmission hiv
is more easily transmitted from the
insertive partner to a receptive partner
for both heterosexual for penile vaginal
sex as well as penile anal sex right the
difference probably is bigger for anal
sex the different the differential is
now being debated again in the
literature it's not exactly clear what
the number is but i think
conventional wisdom is still that it's
it's present and and probably less less
less of a difference than it is for anal
sex but still present
again why does that what does that
matter well if you if you think about
the sort of population level effects of
that
for a two sex population
uh engaging basically heterosexuals
engaging in penile vaginal intercourse
basic biological difference here the
males are always the insertive partners
in that kind of relationship the females
are always the receptive partners for
hiv to transmit through a population
along a chain
of transmission in that um
basically the virus from the point of
view of the virus it needs to go from
male to female
which is relatively easy for it and then
and it has to you know sort of the only
option in a heterosexual purely
heterosexual population is then to go
from
to go from female to male and that's a
bottleneck from the point of view of the
virus right that's less transmissible
and then again male to female so any of
you who have taken chemistry and learned
the sort of mathematics of that when you
have a prob you know a process that has
to go through a bottleneck that tends to
slow it down whereas
um
for one sex population this sort of
bottleneck can can be bypassed at the at
the
sort of level of chains of transmission
where where a male can transmit
relatively easily to another male
um through
as where this male is the receptive
partner and then with another partner
this male is capable of then being the
insertive partner and transmitting
easily again so you don't the virus
doesn't have to go through these same
bottlenecks sort of can transmit easily
through these chains so that's the more
subtle of the two pieces something that
isn't really doesn't get thought about
very much
however you know so that's possible for
msm um
but
isn't universal this issue of role
versatility someone you know a man's
playing both insertive and receptive
role over time with different partners
is hardly universal among msm it's
prevalent certainly it varies widely
cross-culturally in latin america where
i've done some work it's less common
it's more common from for men to to sort
of have
role segregation and consistently play
one role or the other over time and so
you sort of have more of a similarity to
this kind of heterosexual transmission
so so this i don't mean to say that role
versatility is universal among msm and
therefore the virus you know is
you know there's sort of infection super
highways but it's certainly present uh
at different levels and we'll come back
to looking at that
part of why this doesn't get thought
about very much i think in traditional
epidemiology is that in this situation
role versatility is not an individual
doesn't have to be an individual risk
factor so if you look at this case role
versatility this man is insertive
this man is versatile this man's
receptive
all right who
who is put at added risk in this
situation relative to a scenario where
you have role segregation
it's this man right this is not
necessarily a
role versatile man this is in this
simple example this is the man who's
versatile it's his it's the receptive
partner of a versatile man who was put
at added risk right and then he may
himself then turn around be versatile
and put another partner at risk and so
on but you don't necessarily
have to
see you know an individual level risk
factor where you go out and you do a
study and you ask men whether they've
been inserted receptive or both and look
at hiv prevalence you want you're not
necessarily if you do that kind of study
you're not necessarily going to see
versatile men showing higher rates of
hiv prevalence over relative to say men
who are exclusively receptive they
probably won't
but even if you don't even if even
without being able to detect it at the
individual level you still have this
sort of population level risk factor
where the the presence of versatility
the you know just the overall ability
for men to be versatile puts the
population at a higher risk than it does
for a population with real segregation
so that just makes it impos hard or
potentially impossible to measure its
impact directly and any of you who've
ever tried to design a study to get
funding from nih force for us to look
for the impact of something where you
can't detect it at the individual level
and and therefore you have to do some
sort of community level trial or do
something you know you know that
if if it's hard to study at the
individual level it's hard to it's hard
to get funded and it's hard to pursue so
so i think that's part of the
explanation for why we haven't seen much
thought about this
it's also hard so so it's hard to study
um and therefore
and it's also hard to get a sense okay i
can sort of logically explain to you in
three minutes why it is that one might
imagine role versatility would be a
population level risk factor for hiv
transmission and therefore why it might
have something to do with explaining the
disparity between msm and heterosexuals
but it's not necessarily easy to have a
intuitive sense of how important should
that be you know is that
yeah i can understand that that
phenomenon exists and why it would
matter but does it really
you know when all is said and done does
it explain a lot or a little it's very
hard to have an intuitive sense of that
which is why we need to use the tool
that i specialize in which is epidemic
modeling mathematical modeling of
epidemics which is one way to sort of
get purchase on this issue and try to
get a better sense of
okay you know if if this is going on how
big of an impact should it be and is it
something worth worth thinking about
how many of you have ever
taken or or studied epidemic
mathematical modeling for epidemics in
any way
just two okay three
okay so i that's good because i always i
have these requisite slides that try to
explain epidemic modeling to novices at
a more of a philosophical rather than a
methodological level in a few minutes
and so i always put them in sometimes i
skip them but it sounds like it's worth
going through here
so just to give you
for the for the
95 percent of you without modeling
experience just to give you a very quick
sense of what modeling
is and sort of how it fits in with the
rest of of epidemiology
you think about the scientific method
here and what we
allegedly are doing of course we're in
epidemiology which is a
very difficult to do
experiments all the time in um
so this is this is challenged in a
number of ways um it's also i'm when i'm
in an anthropology department so i and
when i work with a lot with cultural
anthropologists so i always put up the
the ways in which i'm aware that that
you know science has has its own issues
but
um this is the piece that i like to that
i'm going to focus on here which is
okay somewhere in the scientific method
you're starting off with a theory about
what you think is is going on and you're
supposed to make a prediction as step
one i you know often designing an
experiment to do it is hard enough but
but we sort of take it for granted that
if i have a theory about what's going on
i can immediately make a prediction
about what it is about what i would
expect to see if that theory is true
so say for instance in this case my
theory is that role versatility
um
explains par explains this differential
there's a they're supposed you know
therefore i should be able to make a
prediction but the problem i mentioned
earlier that it's not it doesn't create
this
individual level risk factor makes it
hard to have any sort of immediately
testable prediction from here
so imagine i have these
sort of set of hypotheses generally i i
think a b c and d are true
and the sort of typical
philosophy of science says well i should
be able to deduce from that okay if a b
c and d are true then i should predict
that z is also true and then i can test
to see if z is true and that helps me
figure out if my antecedents are true
what often happens in the world of of
infectious disease epidemiology is that
not only is it hard to design an
experiment to test if z is true it's
also hard to figure out what z is
supposed to be from your from your
antecedents right and that's exactly
what's true in this case and it is true
a lot of the time in infectious diseases
because infectious diseases are
classic examples of complex systems that
have feedback in them that are
transmitted on highly structured
non-random contacts with with
thresholds and all these sort of
complicated complex systems features
right this is the sort of you know
classic example everyone has to put up a
figure of a complex network to show how
you know how
complicated this world is
um
and this is sort of this this set of
slides gives you an example of how
how it matters you know sort of how the
consequences of getting the sort of
details of these complex systems right
can be
so
just as an example
imagine a population
in which
everyone has either one two or three
sexual partners okay
and here's the distribution in the
population about 40 of people have one
sexual partner about 40 percent have 45
percent of one sexual partner 45 have
two sexual partners and about 10 have
three
the mean number of sexual partners in
this population is 1.68
right
if you and if you assume that beyond
this people sort of choose their
partners randomly and you use modeling
tools and you simulate
what this population would look like
as a network this is this is basically
what it looks like it looks like there's
a bunch of other sort of isolated
monogamous couples and then this is sort
of the
the heart of the system this is where
where most of the action is
if you imagine a slightly
more active population in which now a
few more people have three sex partners
then the mean number of sex partners in
this population has gone up
by six one hundredths of a partner
this is what the network now looks like
if you imagine a scenario in which it's
gone up
six one hundredths of a partner more
and you simulate everything from that
this is what the network looks like
and then
if you
imagine it goes up 6 100 of a partner
more to 1.86 and you simulate that this
is what it looks like okay
if you went out and do once you know
sort of one
you know you have a
you have some hypothesis about your
population and you imagine what you
expect disease hiv transmission to look
like in that population and that's a
population that has 1.68
partners on average and you have another
one that has this would you you know are
you necessarily going to be able to
predict
is your model going to be able to
predict that
you know the sort of difference between
this and this no because
again this is just a point about how
these are complex systems and complex
systems have threshold effects in them
with that are very non-linear and all of
the issues that arise from that so
you know i think most people would be
very hard-pressed to be able to use any
kind of formal logic to predict
that a population with this
distribution of networks would have prob
very
this distribution of sexual partners
would very likely have a large
uh std epidemic and this one would have
a very small one right and so these are
the only way you can sort of see this is
using these kind of mathematical
modeling tools simulating populations
and spreading you know simulating
disease on them in
in the computer and and testing it that
way so that's just a that's just my
little
hand wavy p on to modeling to explain it
in five minutes i i don't explain all
the methods of it but just to give you a
flavor
of some of the reasons why it can
provide insight that it's very hard to
get from other forms of
real real data yeah
modeling however shouldn't is not sort
of the opposite of real data good
modeling uses real data as as part of
its part of its starting point
so our aim in this paper coming back to
the original questions
was essentially the sort of modeling
thought experiment
which is to think about this
differential between msm and
heterosexuals and
and to
to frame it as a thought experiment for
the moment and say how large a
difference in epidemics might we see
between an msm population and a
heterosexual population
if they were identical in their
behavioral characteristics their numbers
of partners people have and and the way
those partnerships are put together but
they differ only in these two basic
characteristics that i mentioned before
that there's a uh the it's sort of
including the the transmissibility
difference uh between
vaginal and anal sex and considering the
sort of one sex two sex issue and the
fact that that msm can be versatile
so i'm not saying this is true that msm
and heterosexuals are identical in their
behavioral characteristics and the
lesson for you when you're publishing
science is that the the
popular press that picks up on this
paper
totally misunderstood that point and and
you know their headline was researchers
show that that gay men and heterosexuals
have exactly the same sexual behavior
which of course we said five times in
the paper we are not saying that gay men
and heterosexuals do have exactly the
same sexual behavior but
this is a thought experiment but of
course that was what that was what some
of the reports said
and so we're going to use this
mathematical model and we're going to
parameterize it with these two data sets
now i i just said i'm not saying that
they're identical in sexual behavior um
but i am going to
make a claim that
they're a lot less different in sexual
behavior than them than the person down
the street than my mom probably thinks
they are
at least in terms of what matters from
the point of view of hiv which is
unprotected
anal or vaginal sex partners
we don't have or at least i was unable
to find data from two different sources
one of msm and one of heterosexuals that
asked the same questions in the same way
that really allowed
us to be able to compare and look at
this
but this is this was sort of the best we
were able to do at the time which was to
go to the nhsls the national health and
social life survey which was a sort of
nationwide
stratified sample of the us population
that asked all about their sexual sexual
health and sexual history this is ed
laumann study from the university of
chicago
and to ask them about the
number of sex partners they've had in
the in the last 12 months and this is
what the distribution looks like
the vast majority you can sort of piece
together all the different tables and
you can find out that the vast
majority of the sexual partners they're
reporting here are vaginal sex partners
and condom use was low
right from the from the urban men's
health study which was sort of one of
the one of the
uh
early social survey sexual health and
sexual behavior surveys of msm done in
four u.s cities this is the distribution
of any sex partners for them so you can
certainly see at this level a huge
difference right a much higher number of
of msm are reporting having had sex with
two or more partners in the last 12
months than are than is the population
as a whole of the us right the median
here is one the median here is three
and the mean is pretty high however
again that's all sexual contact which
includes
you know oral sex etc lots of different
things if you only look at anal sex
partners that distribution goes down
considerably
and if you only look at unprotected anal
sex partners which again is uh what we
mostly care about as ha in the world of
hiv
you see precisely the same number of of
men in the two plus category
you see per you know you see a far far
higher number of men who are having zero
partners than you see over here right
these are presumably many of these are
or
either are or think they're in mutually
monogamous relationships
um
you know is presumably what's going on
here over here you see
you know the median for msm 70 you know
two well over about two-thirds of the
population are having no unprotected sex
at all no one protects anal sex the mean
number of partners is 1.3 right so from
the point of view of the relate of the
activity that matters
for
uh
for hiv spread this is
you know this is pretty low i think this
is this is
not
not you know sort of this sort of off
the charts impression that most people
have i think
so again not saying that heterosexuals
and msm are exactly the same i don't
have information about how long this
tail is they don't report what the mean
is we can't say that i don't have
information about the you know how far
out this tail goes but i do know the
mean is 1.3 which is not very high it
can't go out very super far
okay so
just to give a little sense about the
model without going deeply into the
liter the the methods of mathematical
modeling which are hard to convey
quickly um
for those who do know it's a
deterministic compartmental model much
of the work that i do is in agent-based
and network modeling but this paper is
not for various reasons
and basically we're modeling men
who come into a population zero negative
and then consider convert and leave the
population we're going to consider men
having three different
levels of
of
unprotected anal intercourse per year
which is coming from this distribution
here
with an overall mean of 1.3
and then we're gonna divide the
population up by roll so you know when
we're modeling the heterosexual
population everyone's either male or
female when we're modeling the msm
population men can be can be versatile
or there are some men in the population
who will always be inserted if there are
some who will always be receptive
in the simulation
and the probability you sort of put all
these pieces together using these
mathematical modeling tools you derive
equations for the probability someone in
a zero that's zero negative is going to
become zero positive as a function of
all these things they're how much
you know how many partners they're
having based on their activity level um
who those partners are based on the
mixing patterns whether or not those
parts are seropositive and then some
model for the probability of
transmission given serodiscordant
contact
so this very simple model that only
basically looks at three characteristics
of people what their activity level is
what their what their
role is and and whether or not they're
positive or not leads to this set of
equations which is big and messy so
this is a lesson for those
who are interested in mathematical
modeling that it gets complicated
quickly and those of you who are reading
mathematical modeling papers and you're
and thinking why didn't they include
this this this this this and this in the
paper this is why because just a simple
paper leads to this set of equations
that has to be solved
in terms of the numbers we put into the
base model we have sort of um we use the
that that distribution in the in the
slide i showed before of the fraction of
the population in each of these
categories uh in each year at any given
time
um and then again the none none low is
people who have one partner per year
high is people who have more than one
and again the
the numbers of partners they're having
per year works out so that the mean of
this distribution is 1.3
um
this is heterosexuals are 50 50. uh msm
um those of you who've worked with msm
data will probably won't be surprised
that more men report being exclusively
tops than reporters being exclusively
bottom which is a bit of a mathematical
impossibility but we we did the best we
could with that
and then
for assortative mixing what you see in
these data sets is that
again this is sort of this is sort of
capturing the tendency towards mutual
monogamy for someone who only has one
partner
um you know their partner is more likely
than chance to also be have only one
partner right so this is capturing that
tendency towards mutual monogamy that's
in the data of course the data on this
are always suspect because
not everybody knows
whether their partners actually are
being
mutually monogamous but at least
you know we're going to go with what the
data say for now at least
we took the probability of transmission
for act from uh vargas's uh
meta-analysis that that of all the
previous studies
now we you know we have much better data
than we did at the time about acute
infection and i'll come back to that at
the end but these are the numbers we
took acts per partnership came from the
urban men's health study
based on the different kinds of
partnerships
these numbers we essentially made up
and
voila
okay so
simulation one of the of the population
was let's let's simulate msm
using their observed behavior and their
observed versatility rate about what was
it
fifty percent of about fifty percent of
men reported being versatile and fifty
percent of men reported being well
segregated over the course of a year so
we simulate that population
um and lo and behold we get an epidemic
that's
in the low teens in terms of prevalence
right that's where it stabilizes which
thankfully is a very realistic epidemic
so it's always very reassuring when you
go in through all this trouble you build
this model you know you're leaving some
pieces of reality out but your results
you know your first model still comes
out with something realistic
um
some of you may be saying well that's
not realistic because of this time scale
here right that's not how the epidemic
actually played out it didn't take 75
years to get up there and we are we're
well aware of that the reason it doesn't
take 75 years to get up there is that
the behaviors that msm are reporting in
the 90s and and in the in the in the
2010s the 2000s
are not the same behaviors that were
taking place in the 1970s right so
things were different in 1970s this was
able to go up much faster behavior
change right but we could go through all
the hassle of modeling that entire
process and how behavior change we don't
have necessarily have good data to do
that that's an entire huge enterprise
all in itself that that ted white is
actually
applying for funding to look at
that the sort of early years and how
things played out
instead what we do is basically say well
we're not we're interested in sort of
what the
where this equilibrates we're not as
interested in
in interpreting the time scale perfectly
okay
so that's that's sort of where our model
says msm
who are engaging in the behaviors that
were happening in the 90s and are doing
so
with you know who are having anal sex at
the rates observed in the 90s and her
and are
having versus engaging in versatility at
the rates that we see that's that's sort
of what's happened so my first question
you know one of my first two points at
the beginning was how much does
versatility matter it's hard to get a
sense of what what the population level
impact of that should be so let's do a
thought experiment number one which is
what if all men were versatile instead
of only 50 of msm in the us saying
they're versatile
all men were versatile they're having
the same numbers of partners all of
everything else is the same it's just
that whenever they come together it's a
coin flip as to who's insertive and
who's receptive
and this is you know what the model says
prevalence would increase to from 13 or
so up to 19 percent right so the so
again no more no one's having any more
sex than they were before just
this is the impact of that
you know ability for msm to be versatile
and if no men were versatile if they all
you know came stamped as as
heterosexuals do with you know insertive
or receptive
from the point of view of of the
behavior that transmits the virus
in fact the epidemic would be
considerably smaller it would be down it
would equilibrate down at around nine
percent right so
so just from that fact alone men being
able to you know this men being able to
be versatile and doing
men being able to be versatile at their
observed levels of
at the sort of existing partnership
network
you know the degree to which they are
versatile allows the epidemic to vary
between 9 and 19
and the sort of observed epidemic a full
third of it
can sort of be attributed to in this in
this counter factual way to the
existence to this sort of popula you
know this ability for msm to be
versatile and for heterosexuals not to
so you can imagine this this simulation
here is msm with no versatility with
anal transmissibility this could also
represent heterosexuals if if we were on
some other planet and heterosexuals
always never had vaginal sex they only
had anal sex
this
right so if heterosexuals
did that this is sort of where they
would be because they're not capable
you know the versatility is not there
but they are you know this would be what
would happen if they had anal sex if
however you simulate the same
sexual network behavior
but with heterosexual vaginal vaginal
transmissibility probabilities anyone
want to guess what happens
you don't there's no epidemic at all
okay so heterosexuals again and all the
behavioral data are coming from the msm
report so basically what this is saying
that is that if heterosexuals behaved
exactly like gay men seem to in the
united states in terms of the numbers of
sex partners the numbers of unprotected
sex partners they have but instead but
because of the probability of vaginal
transmission being lower because they
can't be versatile they would be below
the epidemic threshold hiv would die out
another way to think about that is in
order for
them for for
in order to get heterosexuals to have an
epidemic the size of ms that msm do
they would need to have 2.7 times as
many partners as msm as msm do so
they'd have to have a lot of partners
to just to get an epidemic the size that
msm seemed to in order to have the same
hiv prevalence that msm did
in
during the sort of initial course of the
epidemic it takes longer for it to take
off then they would need to have 4.8
times as many partners on average as msm
do
holding all else equal now let's sort of
go the opposite direction in order to
where's the point below which the
epidemic dies out
okay those of you who've
no none very few of you have studied
epidemic modeling but i encourage you to
do so and when you do one of the first
things you'll learn about is this
concept of reproductive thresholds and
and you know feedback and how below a
certain point an epidemic is
unsustainable in a population and it
dies out this sort of herd immunity
effect and all of that
we saw the heterosexual epidemic dying
out if they even if they engaged in
behavior similar to msm where's the
point at which it dies out in each
population
if you hold all else equal the sort of
distribution of the population in each
category
or you just change the mean numbers of
partners that people are having in order
for the hiv epidemic to die out
essentially in the population to become
unsustainable without sort of repeated
reintroductions without overlap with you
know without idu
you know with injection drug use with
just this sort of sexual behavior
transmission
in isolation
in order to keep make that
self-sustaining heterosexuals
you know can be anywhere below having
basically three three unprotected sex
partners per year on average in the
population and they're going to have an
epidemic that's really not sustaining
very you know that's not
that's not becoming a full-fledged
generalized epidemic
msm on the other hand need to be below
1.06
right
and i would say this is sort of above
most populations you're going to see in
a lot of places this is
this is quite low right so 1.06 is just
a little bit above one right and i and
obviously is a much harder thing to
obtain at a population level than this
any of you who are wondering at the
moment
what is this
is he ever going to talk about
heterosexual transmission of hiv in
sub-saharan africa and why that you know
i will
if that if you're holding that in the
back of your mind i'll come back to it
so
but in the u.s
holding all everything else in the model
equally heterosexuals it's a lot easier
to
to
you know to eliminate a self-sustaining
generalized epidemic among heterosexuals
in the us than it is among msm
yeah
right okay we started 10 10 minutes late
so
um
this is the part i think is very
important
yeah we're good
okay this is the part i think that is
very important
of a message to get out to the
population as a whole which is that msm
are much more susceptible in this model
i should say
and again it's just it's a model to hide
the high-risk behavior of a small subset
of the population so the proportion of
the population that's having more than
one partner per year
is only 20 or so right
um if you take that rate
again in this population right the
average number of parties is 1.3 if you
if if you take the rate of that high
activity class and high is not
necessarily all that high and you and
you triple it so suddenly we for
whatever reason we stopped doing
prevention we stopped getting the
message out there the just the small set
of people start having higher numbers of
unprotected sex partners and you you
sort of triple the number of partners
they're having
prevalence for hiv
hiv prevalence for msf for heterosexuals
goes up seven fold for msm it goes up 28
fold
if you only look at the low activity
people so the so you you raise the
what's going on with the the 20 of the
population that's
that's engaging and has multiple
partners
what happens to the people who aren't
having multiple partners and remember
that that
you know i put in that mixing by
activity level so the vast majority of
these people's partnerships are with
other low activity people but they have
some with high activity people
if you just
look at the people who are you know
basically once a year
they you know have a
you know whatever they get drunk they go
out and you know they
they kind of
make a mistake or whatever
prevalence at year 20 for heterosexuals
is one in one in a thousand for msm is
26 percent
right
so
right so
we'll come back to this but i think this
tells a lot about
well we'll come back to this
and to sort of i pull those numbers from
this chart this basically says if this
is the this is the level of partnering
of the high activity class relative to
what we observe in the data so this is
the observed data
and this is hiv prevalence and this is i
just pulled out if we increased it up to
three-fold right if we increased it to
three-fold
heterosexual this is prevalence in the
low activity class heterosexuals still
don't have much of an epidemic the
general population is not still really
at risk whereas right they don't become
heterosexuals don't become that much at
risk until
really you you you know you have to get
to levels that are are really enormous
for msm this is where we're at
according to the data
we don't have to be very high above
where we're at
for you know the activity of of the high
activity men
to reach the point where suddenly
everyone is just put back again at
enormous risk right so this is a this is
an argument about the interconnectedness
of populations and the importance to the
population as a whole of prevention
among subsets of the population
so some of the implications are that
basic and
frankly unchangeable
demographic and biological factors can
play major roles in increasing the
susceptibility of msm in the popul
msm populations to hiv
partly this is a very pessimistic
message
one piece of it that i'd like to focus
on is that the public health community
and the general public and my mother
should not assume that
what we saw what i started off with that
that persistent differences in msm and
heterosexuals in terms of hiv and other
stds the numbers aren't exactly the same
but other stds you see similar issues
are due only or even primarily to
differences in individual behavior
and i pulled i thought
it came out too small this is the
wikipedia page for lgbt stereotypes and
i pull this out because there's an
entire section on the stereotypes of of
gay men as being extremely promiscuous
having large numbers of unprotected anal
sex partners and all of that and then
they cite this this paper as counter
evidence for that again they kind of get
the argument wrong because we didn't say
that they don't but anyway
they are doing this and so
um i'm happy to see you know i was much
happier to see this paper being cited
here than elsewhere in the literature
because this is where it actually i
think matters this is this is a message
i want to see
get out it also means that i get to use
my favorite joke which is that now i can
honestly say that if you look up lgbt
stereotypes in the encyclopedia you'll
find me
oh sorry i love that joke i can tell
that all i can tell that joke all day
long
why does this matter well it matters i
think this is something ted and i have
talked a lot about and something that
came up in the podcast today i think
what happens is
public health
there's this sort of ongoing
battle is maybe too strong maybe battle
isn't too strong a word but there's this
ongoing tension between
you know public health discourse public
health
working on hiv prevention among among
gay men in the u.s many of whom are gay
men themselves not all many of whom are
and
you know other segments of the of the
gay male community the men's health
movement and that that sort of thing who
where there's a sort of
fear that any time we the the public
health community focuses on it and
brings to light the these persistent
disparities and and
and the fact that something needs to be
done about them and we have to you know
come up with novel ways to do that
there's kind of a discussion that comes
out that by simply pointing them out and
acknowledging their existence where
we're sort of increasing the stigma on
gay man where we're you know because
there's sort of the implicit assumption
that well the persistent difference can
only
you know the main by by pointing it out
we're sort of saying it's because gay
men are all promiscuous and we're sort
of playing we're fostering those
stereotypes ourselves as even as we're
trying to engage in hiv prevention among
this population so there's this kind of
backlash that comes
and i think
and many wonderful true points are
raised as i started out with at the
beginning about how we also need to be
thinking about homophobia and stigma and
and all these sort of broad structural
issues all of which matter as well they
absolutely do but i think part of what
gets lost in there is this piece and i
am
i guess my main goal here is to have
this message somehow
help
bridge that gap and make people realize
that the persistent difference was just
pointing them out and discussing them
and really making them making it aware
that they're there
does not have to mean that we are you
know pointing fingers and saying it's
because gay men are all promiscuous and
we have to change that that there's
there's middle ground
um that hopefully can be productive
the pessimistic piece of it is that msm
will remain relatively vulnerable to hiv
and sudden directs even when you shift
behavior right as we've seen
which means you know this there's no
magic bullet that comes out of this in
fact quite the opposite um
more broadly the you know the more broad
issue is that there are factors other
than individual level unsafe sex unsafe
partners that can predispose or protect
different populations from std epidemics
i think another area that i don't have
time to talk with today is work on
racial disparities in hiv among msm in
the u.s where you see black msm
reporting the same exact level sometimes
even lower levels of unprotected sex
numbers of partners then do white msm
and yet have much higher rates of
hiv i think there's an you know another
sort of network piece going on there i
don't have time to get into it what
about africa
right a large
generalized heterosexual epidemic
there's at least there's a couple things
going on that make
hiv among heterosexual transmission of
hiv in africa different than in the us
one is
higher rates of infectivity for a
variety of reasons one is lower
circumcision rates one are co-infections
with with you know we've seen work on
malaria and the syndemic effects of how
the sort of
activation of the immune system in an
environment with large numbers of of
circulating
uh infectious diseases causes the immune
system to be more
activated which means more t cells so
what so so there are issues about higher
infectivity
in africa there's also other structural
patterns that were not included in my
model at all
and this is an entire other
piece of of modeling work who and if you
are if you real in terms of the
existence of relation of concurrency in
sub-saharan africa versus in the u.s in
heterosexuals and um
if you if you want to hear more about
this because i'm out of time martina
moore any any paper by martina morris in
the last 15 years has been uh probably
been on this topic this is an entire
separate literature that seeks to
explain
the differentials in hiv between
sub-saharan africa and the rest of the
world for for heterosexuals not in terms
of numbers of partners because lifetime
numbers of partners are very similar but
in terms of in terms of
network patterns larger than just
numbers of partners
so there's lots of limitations
which you can read really quickly
and let me just say very quickly for the
future many of those limitations
have to do with things that were left
out of the model
um and that was because that was a sort
of fairly
quick and dirty model to try to get that
peace out there but i'm now involved in
a much more elaborate project
um i like to call it the mother of all
msm hiv models it's just it keeps
growing um
which is what ted mentioned at the
beginning which basically the short
answer the short piece of this is that
it basically re-includes all of it
includes a lot more detail so if so if
your critiques of your model are you
didn't include a b c and d get back to
me in three years because we will have
included all of those
um
and that just says all that and then
thanks to lots of people um
including ted for bringing me here and
for lots of fruitful discussions over
the years about
about
hiv prevention among gay men